cuando empezó la pandemia mientras los
países se confiaban en el líder
brasileño seguía saludando a los suyos
sin mascarilla y sin distanciamiento
social para bolsonaro el virus no era
para tanto
después de la puñalada que recibí no va
a ser una gripe sin ya lo que me va a
derribar de acuerdo bolsonaro se
contagió de kobe 19 y aún así continuaba
negando su gravedad y promoviendo
medicamentos de dudosa efectividad como
la hidroxi cloroquina las imágenes de
hospitales y cementerios saturados daban
la vuelta al mundo
castigando especialmente el amazonas
donde han muerto más de mil indígenas
una región golpeada por la aparición de
variantes más contagiosas este
coronavirus es un problema muy grave
tanto para ustedes como para los pueblos
indígenas pero al presidente brasileño
no le importamos el virus no derribó la
salud de bolsón ado pero sí su
credibilidad internacional y sus niveles
de popularidad la ciudadanía comenzó a
protestar más frecuentemente en su
contra la falta de medidas y de insumos
le han llevado a enfrentarse en diversas
ocasiones con gobernadores y jueces tu
cara
lo que quieren estos tipos en nuestra
sangre nuestra libertad esa es la verdad
lo que hicieron con el virus la
porquería del gobernador de sao paulo el
de río de janeiro exactamente eso el
ministerio de salud vio desfilar ya al
cuarto ministro en un año es en este
punto cuando parece que al fin el
presidente bolsonaro va a enfrentar
frontalmente la pandemia con la creación
de un comité para coordinar medidas
semanales con los gobernadores y la vida
en primer lugar resolvimos entre otras
cosas que se creara una coordinación
conjunta con gobernadores así como el
presidente del senado federal que ha
dado un panorama que alertan que todavía
puede empeorar queda la esperanza de un
lento proceso de vacunación para
revertir la situación